welcome for this video welcome fathers
welcome to this video and it's for round
three of the tal memorial let's check
out the games and i'll start with dumb
mayara off against chronic ya Kramnik
started with zero points out of two
games it's probably never happened to
him before in in his recent memory maybe
as a kid but never before and it's
playing against bama y are offered a
good start with one and a half points
let's see what happened we get an enzo
with quincy to enter kramnik for quite a
long while already yeah it's um the main
protection practitioner of this line
with castles and d5 this is some one of
them most interesting ways would like to
play against this on the ideas with
castles and d5 to simply play for
maximum development one absolutely key
point is that after c takes d5 in this
position black place 94 it doesn't
recapture the ideas that here 94 quincy
to ed 5 allows a quick further
development with Bishop f5 see 596 is
very aggressive so white very rarely
nowadays takes on d5 this is the
absolute mainline and maybe chronic here
I'm put a move forward in this position
which hasn't been seen so often he plays
now 27 in fact he had some years ago
already played this position more than
once and again skousen for example he
had played c5 which ended in a draw at
Queen t7s an interesting alternative
Queen c 2 and c 5 this is Blakes idea he
doesn't really care about any double
points here he wants to open up the
position as as soon as possible the main
issue for widest that is king it says
sit in the middle and it takes two moves
at least two moves to get castled so
black wants to be really quick c5 takes
rook c8 intending to take with the rook
and this initiates a forced sequence now
Bishop f6 takes Queenie for so
Mammadyarov is really testing of this
piece of preparation attacking the rook
yeah black now in fact has got more than
one interesting move what chronic plate
is will be five sacrificing this rook
and gap it's a is it a sacrifice and
it's let's check midi arif didn't take
the rook what we can look at this like
that simply takes i'll be too and yeah
now the rook is singing and there's only
one square you can only go here after
this black can play 96 and this way
catch the queen the only continuation of
something like this and here at the end
of the a porn is the problem White has
no way to save this pawn leaving black
with them probably winning endgame so
return you cannot really take the rook
so what should why do you play that B
form this is a false move the idea is to
play III and we see that this was the
intention now we're taking the Queen and
yeah the Queen just retreated if we look
at this this position before takes if
white now takes on a eight once again 96
or
even this move is really dangerous yeah
in fact I'm a geographer doesn't really
need to calculate this to be honest
probably occur it was clearly in his
preparation more time than he started
the game with so I'm after Queen B 7
here he gave the check and the thing is
also why it needs to be M cautious if
you play him let's say I just did that
say would you take him and take him say
after this you need to be really
cautious because black is better
developed and it might happen that in a
position which is fairly symmetrical
Black is just the one tempo I had to get
on the second rank and then you're in
trouble so what needs to be cautious
here gave this check and then played b5
yeah quite logically trapping this
Bishop so black is forced to take it
rook be one this was the idea
threatening to win the bishop a 6 if all
this is pretty much forced and now f5
attacking the Queen Queen needs to move
and Queenie for all chrome legs prep
queen is attacking the rook and offers
this trade so the rook is saying and
white basically has no one no way to
continue the game played Queen h6 King
e73 g5 and we got to draw a repetition
is there something else Queen you follow
yeah white could have taken
something like this I can also just grab
him not a snatchy 5 i'm sorry of course
you need to get it back overlook that
need to take the piece first and let's
see here whoop dat takes 96 the problem
is that you will probably not keep the
spawn and if you don't keep the point
you're judged you're just worse whiter
simply has no big idea to continue the
game it I really understand the decision
to make the draw considering that
dissolve chrome next preparation
obviously it didn't spend his back on
one hour 40 and finished the game with
more timely clock here you actually took
a while maybe try to figure out if you
can play for win can yet maybe get just
check it but white can take castle like
King assess very am very endangered say
if you take here Queen age seven Queen a
jade yeah cannot do that yeah so very
very young short draw which probably was
all prepared by my chronic i think it
was glad to have such a non game and get
into the the rest day after those two
losses okay next game girlfriend and
drinkin we got default e6 c4 Bishop b4
check um yeah this is sometimes called
the carers defense the great player of
the yeah it's hard to tell i was i
wanted to say off the 50s 60s but he
also won this classic every tournament
in the thirties even so pork eres is
some one of the all-time greats one of
the best players never to become
champion 80 sometimes is the the
namesake for this variation with the
submission before check it's very
similar to the Bogle Indian of course
but it costs got some some subtle points
I'm very a very good opening actually I
think this would be immensely popular if
it wasn't for the fact that here if
always the best smooth and supposing it
to a French defence and yeah why the
French is a good opening or though it's
probably still better than full white in
comparison then this okay it's not like
white is in trouble but it's it's simply
quite okay for Black Knight c3 is nicely
answered by be six or c5 both of us were
quite good Fisher Knight d2 we see in
the game and Bishop b2 black has
multiple ideas he can play a 5 which was
interesting i can just take and play for
a very simplified position okay 92
played by Gelfond he very often plays
this against the bogo and c5 I'm sorry
c5 yeah this attacks the sentient we see
that white immediately gets the bishops
but the thing is queen is not so great
on d to obviously problem is not much
choice if you take with the bishop then
black may even protect it with the five
you won't get the ball back so this is
so one white miss places some his queen
of it and black actually opens up the
position against the bishops the some
sounds maybe a bit strange to to some
but it's some quite often is the
strategy of opening up the position
against bishop some is in fact the right
one it's just a matter of
the concrete position here the issue is
if you give white time he's lagging in
development you give white time then you
will catch up with Bishop b2 b4 Bishop
b2 and so on like before but should be
to Bishop e2 castles he's got two
bishops at just a great position if you
give right time he will be a much much
better so you need to let's say strike
while the iron is hot and open up the
position for your nights and we see that
here ya might be five separate ebay to
lose but blankets quickly developing
rock t 896 b6 Bishop e7 so quickly
getting the pieces out and the Queen
here also helps to prevent easy
development ni b 5 is interesting
attacking or threatening 92 c7 and
blacks only got to the samsung f3 Andy
for this was wise idea but the ce5 you
form which should be six black has got
very good development and Bishop b3 is
an interesting move itself not helping
the development but controlling a very
important square if you imagine that in
the future rook wants to use the default
then we should be three years rather
problem for that idea yeah black Scott
no problems whatsoever property eight
and I white try to get rid of this
bishop it's very hard to to not play
Bishop t1 yeah black is quicker on the
default enter after this we had the
repetition yeah very short game 2333
moves the problem is that I think both
sides have fun slight problems to to not
to not make it this repetition if
anybody black maybe could do
thing Gavin also down to 20 minutes you
really spend time to try to avoid this
way stuff of the white pieces it's
really a bit of a waste if you give it
give up the dumb yeah slide the edge of
the the first move so so so quickly yeah
this is a rather good opening for black
really I really believe it it's it's not
any worse compared to one let's say the
news 0 for instance the only issue is
the French defense with to e4 but
galfond doesn't play one year for so
it's unlikely that he would play before
here to get to the French yes correct I
think draw let's check on la camara
against coyoacán next and we got a goon
felt very surprising choice kayaking is
actually am one of the players with a
very narrow opening repertoire he
usually against default place the the
NIMS oh and the Queen's Indian and I
cannot really recall him playing the
goon fault maybe he's some experimenting
with some new openings but the ghoul
father's some really a surprising yeah
now can we are playing a sideline with
Bishop d2 also played this rather
quickly and we get this kind of position
which is still a fairly typical one for
the good felt castles 6 everything's
rather rather standard 97 and
we got this straight yeah this is really
interesting pawn structure um my first
reaction to this wassman isn't this
rather uninspiring for white what
exactly am is why it's idea here the
thing are the idea that immediately
comes to mind is okay like we'll get
this night 26 and would even be better
blocking the pole protecting be seven
preparing something to eat the night on
d6 so what you want to do um yeah the
only issue is you won't ever get there
it's a simply tricky for black to get in
this maneuver and if you don't manage to
get the night to d6 it is not easy to
play this position in fact the the
problem is the fact is we are now on
move 15 and 5 moves later six months
later coyoacán is really in trouble very
quickly is in trouble but I cannot
really believe that this position should
already be am a big advantage for white
black should have some sort of Defense
certainly to get a playable position I'm
not sure however what's the most precise
way to play it should be um what is
playing actually it's Knight to e5 I
don't really think this is helping but
um I'm not sure maybe Queen f6 this is
some move that came to my mind attacking
the pot still
allowing the Queen them something like a
rupee one or queen bee three be a day
for something like this rupee eight and
this also looks slightly better for for
white but it doesn't really look fatal
if I play something like this for
instance black has some more than one
idea you even go here maybe intending to
play see form the problem is in the game
it really gets ugly quickly so that
somewhere around here there must be an
improvement I actually think maybe white
is somewhat better anyway but you should
try to improve on on the next couple of
moves after this and queen d 6 and the
problem is this night it's not really a
stable piece white has this F for ideas
and the knight on d5 I mean how do you
get to the six now it's rather difficult
the additional problem is what are you
doing after loopy why you don't really
want to play rupee eight but you
probably need to and he did debate b6
and this actually I think it's the point
where black has has real trouble and
problems to stay in the game Brooklyn an
ugly droop to d8 I was also examining f5
which is of course the risky move simply
exposing the six square but at least it
is as an activist maybe Bishop to b5
looking at the eight square F 422 just a
possible line intending loopy form of
naughty little [ __ ]
p for the problem is that this is not a
stable peace only five rupee aid also
has prevented all the terms you cannot
connect it or protect it with rookie aid
and something like let's say f3 it's not
really helping much even a move like
Queenie three years is quite good now
it's already somewhat tricky you played
rock da then this is met by very strong
reply Bishop to a six yeah now of course
black cannot take on d5 gap is your
basics would be eight and c4 and now the
problem is that you can add one more
move Bishop to b5 the problem is that
this Bishop is always controlling he ate
and black simply has has no chance to
get them get on the e-file if you try
this now just for argument's sake
there's this one winning at the pond as
the the night is saying and it's a bin
so this is forced and this is winning
for white we will even have excellent
chances to win the b6 bond Knight to f6
and Queenie to this is the problem
controlling the open file they're only
open file is something the black still
cannot get the night 26 it's impossible
even with the night only six it wouldn't
be great anymore but it would be rather
helpful yeah what is some black supposed
to do we play them Ruby seven how to
give them advice if you play nothing
move then there's some more than one
good idea white can even try to play a
for fi first
it says excellent something for white
also Queenie 7s keeping a very nice edge
attacking the born yeah let's add simply
horrible for black and I really cannot
believe if you go back like four or five
moves that it was such a terrible
position yeah i think around here there
must be some improvement cunaehr six I
don't know but it's clear that this is
really terrible and I think with
excellent technical play why should
probably even win this and back and war
i did a pretty good job here brooke be
three andrew III they're very nice not
difficult but a good maneuver doubling
on the farm and blackest tried to find
some sort of role for this night but you
see that this very powerful move it
wasn't strictly necessary but it is very
good simply controls all those squares
and this is simply a SAT night it cannot
go to eight of course somebody getting
lost and a black black is like in really
in a straitjacket you cannot get out of
this you try to for f5 for some activity
but of course this weakens the king as
well yeah the Kimura plays a really good
game Ian keeping everything under
control and now the Queen's off but even
the end game is terrible yeah it's no no
defense really 98 so it's something that
black could have tried but look at this
what is black supposed to do now why
does got two possible or not put
possible is wrong potential passed pawns
well those three nopee those three
points are blocked by two pawns and if
like those four h5 there's f5 the
immediate move this is too much those
forms at the front part so the idea is
not possible so he goes h5 and now very
instructive just f3 keeping the porn on
g4 which dominates the night the night
has no square can only go to e8 and yeah
well we saw what happened sir 98 so
blacks play is very limited here here
pledgie 5 the white is just making
making small progress now the SD 67
Bishop to d5 and rook e7 this kind of
ideas I in the position her blackest
black is probably lost and he's been
lost for a while already yeah this is H
4 has a slight mistake but like it's in
terrible shape anyway h4 is a small
mistake and it's a mistake because after
after this this year White has the first
win and we see nakamura playing this
here first repeats the position a bit
then goes for this Atlas is very strong
and winning the game you need a second
passport and this way you get it now
cannot take care of course you create
and it's a girl so what is blacks
supposed to do yeah that can only take
and then g5 this is the big idea if from
like now takes there's this funny move
very nice and tell you threatening the
promotion and if black takes oops this
is what's a winning easily yes 0 King g6
and now this idea it's it's just too
much very nicely played by Nakamura
these two pawns simply decide the day
Black has no way to get out of this he's
running into some kind of suits one what
is just picking up the points now no way
for black to to defend yeah very nice
game Monica Mora who is actually now on
+1 it can it is if such a such difficult
and tricky situation sometimes in those
tournament la cámara played a horrible
game in round one and lost with white
against Normandy our oven 20 something
moves then he was completely busted
against kramnik and should have been on
on 0 out of 2 in fact kramnik played
this badly and lost even sokhna camera
one against Kramnik and now one again
against kayaking with a very good game
and now his sermon delete not alone in
liberties in the lead +1 and fighting
for the for the tournament victory
winning two games in a row after this is
lawson in round one okay next game let's
go to Anand against most of it and we
got a Roy Lopez Rosa [ __ ] lately and
it's employing the rule rather often
it's always been now French player and
some other openings but the room okay he
also played a five all this life but
lately is playing this more often okay
we gotta zaitsev variation this old
favorite of coppers why turn now has a
wide range of ideas complaint
d5 a form or possible lights or a 3
which is also an online in six Bishop a
to ya this a three Bishop a 2 is
designed to keep this bishop on this
attractive diagonal ya know black went
498 this is of course a maneuver known
from the Brier variation night bh to d7
getting to a nice regrouping queen bee
three it's a funny move by my own onto
the ideas okay simply capture it f7 and
house black supposed to cover it if you
play rookie seven there are some this
idea and on Queenie seven you know or
maybe even this one queeny's happy looks
really ugly quit d sadnesses what
tomorrow played so it's fine it's a
blocking this night but you have time
enough to correct the screen was also
not good i'll be three it was
threatening them but otherwise queen bee
three it's not really a good good square
so we get a pretty typical ruler best
position here why does some attacking
blacks advance pawn this is strong you
cannot keep it there or allow it to just
allow it to stay there for very long if
blacks got time so wide would play some
some 0 moves then black gets to this
with an excellent position so he opens
it up this is correct and now playing on
the queenside a4 and see for this other
moves so very logical play by by Arnold
he's a the one in this game with the
advantage on the queenside mostly due to
the somewhat ugly bishop on b7 the
bishop on b7 is not really structurally
bad
if you look at this point but it just
barely placed him and in fact even if
this is a good Bishop you would rather
prefer to not have it have it exchange
somewhere okay it's not like black it's
in terrible shape I only saying that
this b7 Bishop aslam was a little
problem okay black is playing before
intending this and of course intending a
five if white now plays a nothing move
don't know again this then a five leads
to an absolute big advantage to Black
Knight here the Queen side is closed and
it's it's terrible blacks got the
protected passer here so a five this is
the way to go and yeah this sort of
isolates the beef upon which really
doesn't have a big natural cover for
from from one of the pieces and the game
now evolves around this yeah morrow
regrouped so that the rook is actually
protecting the before porn but it's
still a weakness and honor this quick to
to get his rooks on the attack I hit you
know it took even yeah yeah it's it's
difficult for why to improve blackest
threatening night to c5 to get rid of
this and so he just took kiya Bishop a
three now this loop move was quite good
so how to assess this position I think
it's probably about equal this is a
slight weakness on d6 the black is got
da Pole I think it's really a quite um
correct game up to this point and
in fact it is for a couple of moons that
offhand illogical yeah rook to a ada
surprise me a bit but okay Lucas
supporting the pond and what exactly is
White's big idea here he played 91 this
is a good move the ideas night to d3 and
then see 45 or supporting c4 c5 not
clear if you can play it so quickly we
applied this and now in order to make
any progress wide needs to chop this off
and Quincy one yeah now in this position
97 this is rather rather logical move
and down on plate three going back and
Bishop f4 yeah and here moral plate
Bishop g5 logical attacking this night
and pinning it so this rather
structurally bad Bishop plays a useful
role on g 5 56 Brooke must move Quincy
to getting out of this yeah and here is
an interesting point here amorous of a
Chatham rather simple moves in
comparison to what he played that I
think would have given him very decent
play this is just night f6 the idea is
just to take and take you form and in
fact this is surprisingly difficult to
meet the only a move that really am
prevents this idea is f3 at f3 is really
ugly allowing his check something like
this it's hard to assess but like should
be ok I cannot really believe in this
that you can put
everything on light squares with this
black Bishop still on the board it is it
is very complicated where I can try c5
for example but yeah Knight f6 year was
was an interesting alternative what he
played wasn't wasn't terrible or
anything it was just rather risky let's
see what happened he played f5
immediately attacking with the pawn the
center this is actually ok but it's very
very complicated it takes 9 f six this
was the idea freeing the bishop and
getting the porn back with the with a
big pin if you allow to and white in
order to play for something must must
play sharply and wish you did that he
just played g4 and protected the f5 porn
yeah II for now right to you one back
and the Queen e7 this was more religious
ide sacrifice the spawn but he's got a
strong bishop this is really really weak
and discard the porn here with the
advancing ideas while this bishop on c6
is a bit off side so it's clear that
this isn't a clear-cut porn forum for
white black certainly has some
compensation and in fact if you continue
a couple of Moses's or fairly fairly
logical plate III this is a mistake
actually and I think a very serious one
instead of this here black should go age
five and in fact this is quite okay for
him I'd same would be three can exchange
and then take him giving him giving
black a quite good counter plain white
um cannot really play this
as you can even answer with this move
yeah and what now the night moves
there's this very strong idea Dwight is
really busted here amazingly no way to
defend it absolutely no way yeah quite
quite amazing but okay you don't really
need to calculate all this is just that
that instead of this age five is fairly
normal looking move he probably
miscalculated something he played III
and after takes continued Bishop h4
there certainly was some tactical idea
that it simply failed here white needs
to play some passive moves but it really
keeps everything together and what now
maybe here is rife again was awesome
idea getting some sort of play going in
the game we played 94 and after Queen
III it's it's it's starting to to be
rather easy actually now you find
yourself neat little trick for why it
takes now there's this and this and it's
not so clear but just King g2 is strong
ignoring all this black grabbed here now
you can exchange Queens but it's a yeah
it's it's a poem and this is six Bishop
while being on a somewhat strange place
it also covers if also this pawn is not
any in any danger and black is simply
badly coordinated this F for this Bishop
is especially bad white is simply
winning yeah he played Quincy for but
dumb this is
really helping okay well thanks thanks
thanks our pieces are hanging yeah black
is simply not not coordinated and after
a couple of additional moves yeah jump
like gave away 11 pc to continue for a
couple of moves but it simply lost moral
confers ID earlier actually and here
this is protected and white simply
intends to do something like this and
winds very easily so on yeah good game
by regime not really you cannot blame
him for for any sort of mistake and it
probably should have been a draw if
melissa which will defend it correctly
right before the champ control um
playing the most accurate moves after f5
or simply avoiding at five um in any way
any rate and a good good win by by anand
okay let's go to the final game cars and
kawana yeah a really slow opening kind
of a ratty reversed king's indian setup
and yeah i know a bit about this opening
i play this kind of stuff myself quite
often and it has some some bite to it
but let's see kawana plays one of the
most popular responses and this prepares
the development of the bishop and
anticipates a wide sea forms of course
cards now castle which is quite normal
of course here there also is the more c4
which is actually what i usually play in
this position the idea of this movies
that now the bishop
velopment 2g for that scene in the game
as well can be answered by 95 and this
actually leads to some edge for white
it's not like a dramatic one but why
does somewhat better the drawback of c-4
is that black can simply take the pond
and this is a rather unclear pawn
sacrifice it's um it's really not not
not so obvious what the best
continuation after this is you can even
play here it's quincy two and there's
castles i usually castle but the other
moves are interesting as well um yeah
but council didn't play that this term
as mentioned avoids the line of the game
castles Bishop g4 and now i played the
c4 c6 and here cd5 the idea of CD five
is that after 85 the rising structure
with d3 and d4 is quite interesting for
white leading to an asymmetrical and
quite complicated middle game the
drawback of cd5 however is that what
Caruana played you can take Bishop takes
and c5 and this actually is it this is
exactly the the line that made me
reconsider the move order with castles
and ce4 simply because this is this is
some problem for white I mean if you
play this opening just to get a
completely solid position and
and make a draw or anything then this is
not much of a problem but white cannot
hope for any advantage here it's simply
too solid I mean carzon played 90 396
deform yeah you can play deform that's
also d3 this is what I usually try it
and now then Bishop e7 castles Queen
here rook c8 it's completely difficult
for wide to do anything black is so
solid it's got all pieces out no bad
piece and what exactly is White's plan
in the game d4 and III was played this
is similar to the game Kramnik against
Aronian from the candidates back from
neck got a nice nice edge and shutteth
one and but he missed the the wind later
carles even spent some some time here
surprisingly yeah many things have been
said about his openings this is
certainly not one of the most aggressive
setups so we even have the bishops
traded and rook c8 looxcie 197 yeah and
what what about this position isn't this
completely equal yeah in fact it is if
you ask me I would actually rather
prefer black already it's not it's not
an edge but the problem is what are you
exactly doing with this bishop it's a
completely symmetrical position and this
bishop wants an open position it's not
easy to open it up move like efore needs
to an isolated pawn black can easily
improved pieces night 26 is one of them
and he has got no problems at all um
yeah Nate a 497 yeah and now I'm Calvin
goes for something really curious and
probably
he misjudged some continuation I'm not
really sure what exactly he played 95
after a couple of minutes and this of
course look strange because black can
take this pawn which he did of course he
hit he took it and probably around here
there must must have been some
miscalculation i don't i don't really
know before of course and rugby five I
mean it he cannot really have overlooked
this one right I actually think that he
may we saw this position and after a
three Queen back he believed that he
could do something against this rook
which is some of course in a slightly
awkward position can only go here but
okay it can go to be six and probably to
d6 and back end well Black is upon up
and what exactly is White's compensation
in fact of you um check this position
with with the computer it gives black
gang a solid edge here it sits upon with
very little compensation for white yeah
probably instead of this ambitious move
95 you should have played some some some
dull continuation to make it wrong in
the game oops this was a bit too quick
Queen yet in the game here he tried a
form to simplify the position and open
up this Bishop so that it actually does
something a fourth takes takes rook c5
young what wider is actually dreaming
off as to to exchange some pieces to to
look and game which you can draw and in
fact after a couple of further exchanges
we get an end game with Queen and rook
and queen a look where the queen is
blocking the pole attacking v6
and I think White has rather reasonable
drawing chance yeah he's still active
but still isn't this very weird to want
to tickle notes if I really don't
understand it's not it's avoiding a draw
of course but it's just getting getting
into trouble there must have been some
sort of miscalculation okay we continue
a couple of moves so quite solid I am
rookie for black gum agrees to the UM
Kalugin game yeah what else if you don't
go you can play it something like this
but how do you make any progress here
with those two pawns under pressure all
the time so it went to the look at Kara
think this is correct and it's an extra
porn white place the typical move h for
preventing g5 by black and setting up
the points and in a way that you can
exchange as many pawns as possible yeah
how to assess this of course it's it's
it should be a draw can put this on the
board white controls the seventh-ranked
the pawn cannot move so everything some
pointing towards the draw but let's see
what happens yeah f4 white wants to
exchange as many points as possible and
manages to this is quite quite normal
black girl of course needs to keep some
material on the board if you for example
take here then it's it's just it's just
not enough you don't have enough
material left now this rook is always
some somehow tied to the beep on what
you plato was was much better keeping at
least the edge form on the board and
after takes playing age 5 this preserves
a little bit of something to try form
but it's still not not great
check yeah like has regrouped now is in
front of the pond but in front of the
bonus isn't exactly great as well after
a couple of more moves we're pretty much
nothing happened yeah we came to this
position and it seems that here there's
only one move and this move and that's
also quite simple this move I think
still retains a very very decent drawing
chances you should just go back to be 8
and this is based on them not on the
fact that this is so great this move the
thing is that you simply don't have any
our any any any other one he played
another one Luke f8 but this seems to
fail and because of a fourth line like
now can take yeah you could takes King
jou 6 okay rook yo check what else King
Andrew have six and in fact this is a
lost end game because the king is caught
off caught off and you can check it with
the table base if you like it so it's
the first win and kurama is playing it
perfectly absolutely perfectly now and
one or two stages he only had one move
to to to win Adam he managed the main
issue is that White's King cannot help
you always have those blocking news yeah
like pushes the pawn and rookie for it's
important to shear to the king and now
you simply promote okay and here Carlson
resigned after King g4 dance King g2 and
promotes no way to stop it so cows lost
last year with white
rather we had game he lost 11 rook
endgame again which he should have drawn
I mean he really had some some cover
letter let's rephrase he performed many
many months before the candidates he
hadn't lost the game and defended all
those who rose positions to draw and now
against the one shock in the candidates
and again here he lost one of those end
games yeah quite surprising he also lost
against one how this kind of end game
which he should have drawn yeah but it
was a weird game anyway really what was
95 this 95 idea this is really strange
would be interesting I didn't have any
time today to UM to check the the press
conference and would be interesting to
to learn what the idea was behind this
this move maybe it was really a very
simple miscalculation so what this means
cars on the spec on fifty percent and
kawana I assign the harness with the
swing yeah this was the third round of
the Tom memoria from Moscow and tomorrow
is the rest day they have rest days
after three rounds and one rest day not
rest days on so while you back down on
monday with further coverage from this
interesting tournament thanks for
watching